extraordinary superhuman unbelievable
positive strong fearless amazing doctor
the world will not see someone like him
again they simply are not enough words
to describe doctor Karamat Musa this was
a man who gave his life to his
profession and his love to his wife I
loved him I loved him from the moment I
saw him at eighty-four guram it was
still practicing as a GP in the surgery
he ran for 46 years we were doing all
the things that we were told to do and I
just started it's not that this is not
going to happen to him obviously with
high inside earth I would have said we
should have said no he said you're not
going to work anymore but he wouldn't he
wouldn't have accepted that he wouldn't
have accept it was a man of enormous
determination he wouldn't he wouldn't
have agreed to give up work but for a
man that gave so much it was the virus
that claimed his life it's believed he's
the oldest NHS worker to die from Kovac
19 I was what I was hoping to hear to
feel some breath come from it it was
beautiful it was beautiful
I just felt I was missing Poseidon in
the seaside town of Clapton they lined
the streets they cried and paid tribute
to a man who served this community for
decades
a shortstop at the place he treated
thousands of patients dr. Musa clearly
meant so much to so many but none more
so than his grandson Joseph he leaves an
amazing legacy and I admire him and
isn't one of my world role models the
Sun shone on Clacton as Gromit was laid
to rest with his family nearby yet again
Kovac 19 has taken a life so important
to a family and a community it's a huge
gulf for sure I can never never feel I
can just live I'm just gonna live on the
memories of what he was